my name is Eddie Reza Vik I host the TV
talk show called the Dean show I grew up
in Chicago I was born in New York and
spent most of my life all my life in
Chicago have a pretty big family here
and I've been training and teaching
Gracie Brazilian jiu-jitsu Sheridan out
of Mejia the anticodon ago sort of take
up a hideki I would say that the concept
of religion too many youth is a foreign
concept because really at that age it's
about just following what you want to do
your lusts and desires it's about just
getting all you can it's about just
acquiring wealth acquiring money that
becomes a religion a way of life upon
itself technically technically if I was
to put something on paper it used to be
a Muslim but you have to also make a
conscious decision the practica family
wasn't practicing Islam and we know
Islam means submission to the Creator
submitting your will but we were
submitting to our desires
I say alhamdulillah for my grandparents
my grandparents were practicing Islam
but my parents they weren't viola time
me and my husband prayed Eddie come to
visit us in Buffalo sometime I take care
him he pray with us startled and he has
short pants he takes my dress and that
had a really a great impact on me but
then when I would go back home to
Chicago that would be forgotten
Ramadan would come around as I got older
and it was kind of a tradition in the
Bosnian community that maybe you'd give
up alcohol but you wouldn't fast but you
would fast abstain from alcohol but then
when Ramadan was over you're right but
about this rumor dad that's it my
so-called idol was Elvis Presley the way
I really think Eddie was following my
steps - also he was not singer but you
know he he followed the music show
business here in their wild life
shove your a-slash Shabab alerted
already but you see Malik Shah Baba luma
well I can no stay other better desi art
i'm mahalia VA all idea used to come
here for our treatments and during those
times we were talking about different
things than he was very young and
inexperienced and didn't have a much
knowledge about our faith so I was
trying to guide him and one day we were
talking about different issues and we
were talking about debt that had in
Mahalo Mahalo to me I'll see with the
new would Harry Santelli in the kind of
copier case that kind of to be dieting
hey Diane McKenna
well one of the things that I really
remember that stands out and my journey
was a story that I heard from my sister
and she was talking to me about in
Bosnia a son who had came to bury his
mother and as he buried his mother he
had finished left he had lost his wallet
his paperwork the only logical thing was
that as I was bending over the documents
fell in the cupboard in the grave
to his surprise after he got to digging
up the grave he had found he had saw a
sight that had scared him so much and
from there when I heard this story to me
logically I was like look that is an
irrefutable fact that we are also going
to be in that grave it is a very scary
moment and that triggered in something
inside of me that story really motivate
he got me scared and then I went back to
my uncle and I was telling him you know
what my sister had told me this story
and you're always reminding me out about
this and then what he did was he thought
it was interesting he went back to his
shelf and he picked up this book and the
book was on life death in the hereafter
I thought that would be good for him to
read and I didn't really think he's
gonna you know read it maybe a little
bit you know but then he called me like
in few days I know two three days and he
said look uncle you know I read their
book I want to bring it back to you I
said are you sure
so he came back and he and he told me
this really scared me you know so that's
when I thought it was like a turning
point in his life at one point I was in
a elevator and we had got stuck for a
little bit of time and you feel
claustrophobic and that also had
triggered me to think wow imagine if
we're getting scared you know being
stuck in an elevator
being constricted many people are
claustrophobic what about that moment in
the grave when we all visit and then
from there I just really wanted to know
like what happens after death Anna NFC
the Thermopolis are lacunae it's a la
Rose did that that thought a network
that Asia saw hit Collison server demo
coolest madamluna ID I had that
caregiver Washita mother if they do
we're at home for communal modes better
a choleric Fukuoka theorem portal our
caliber on woman right alaya kathira MA
Hill il se has pockets there's one I in
the Quran surah al-anam where I really
can connect to it I connected to it in
my journey and the ayah is talking about
women hi-yah to dunya illallah yo Walla
Walla Darrell hero to Hyrule in lovina
yep taco a fella tap you know Allah and
I was trying to understand I was like
look I'm in this life you know and I'm
experienced these things but it's not
bringing that peace and solace and
contentment and I'm seeing exactly what
Allah is talking about all these people
are trying to do is cut the next man out
to get to the top to outdo this person
you can see that with the celebrities
that many people look out and up to
that's all it really was about about
material things showing off boasting and
at the end you're you might have all the
money but you're bankrupt in the soul
and that's where I was I was bankrupt in
the soul in the heart but alhamdulillah
that I lost funds although he guided me
to Islam and that's where the true
contentment peace and satisfaction boys
- I see like hey like the middle
kind of song - Moo - Coble economy
a lady named Alice panatela Hedda in an
Islam I lost my solace about metallic
silver Hassan Rowhani
a true Carroll t ad raha Gumo Guanajuato
sorta yeah drew home in al-islam Ellen
he died she far away separable Tariq
al-hashemi hey Lanie
- hey it's vanilla Jubal Himachal allah
hater samartha a one-bedroom sugar
Hannity really you have a Serafino Quran
terrible Quran the cool I'm not had a
facade heavens Allah to see I was a cat
a saucepan silent a cool
FEMA's Anna in my house nobody pray five
times a day no in the family all family
nobody
I came over one day and I don't know
what just I just woke him up
I said let's go let's go to the to the
Masjid I thought something happened you
know say let's go for fortune
there was a Masjid Mecca Masjid right
next door but I don't I I don't know we
ended up going to MCC was a bigger
community is saying we go MCC it's more
reward you know it's a couple of miles
almost unbelievable and really then FB
she can say the miracle but I don't
believe the miracle will come to me into
the profits but you know it's too many I
see a lot more see
howdy I see now today I have my shake is
my shake
the change was good not just for Eddie
but for our entire family it's got more
peace and less problems for all of us
generally it's been a blessing you know
what very thankful to Allah I mean a
richest and happiest person on earth
that exists today that's how I feel
alive I know Allah that's the best as
the richness and I think when my father
looks back I mean I want now I see see
my children coming up and you want them
to be on a path of righteousness of
goodness and you can't just a fathom if
they go straight
Masha Masha Allah Spencer Elliman
elected a bad head Isaac he'll have a
salutary liminal Quran a Salah animal
Islam had isn't Allah how the shape
absolutely we know that when we leave
which we will we will leave this dunya
we will separate from this dunya and
we've been told that when we do leave
the Prophet SAW some had told us that
three things will follow us to the grave
that would be your family your wealth
and your good deeds and two will stay
behind but the good deeds come with you
and one of those great good deeds that
also continues to work for you in this
life is a righteous child rahmanir rahim
I made to say I know honey nobody loves
him less even same telephone Galatia
animal it's a miracle of the crowd that
has been memorized by kids at the young
age there's no other book like it we
know take all the books throw them in
the ocean the Quran is the only one
that's been memorized by so many people
millions upon millions
so mother helped Mary Deely Nadia
jujitsu Olivia and Cheryl marijuana
Chicago Salalah column on the carton
Buchanan's Lebanon hashiba storm you can
own a decree mashallah hooey Theory
mother had a silencer had a nod you
hostage and heavy-laden growing up I
used to like to fight and I had to
channel my efforts in something positive
and I got to experience this style of
martial art I was really taken away and
I got really addicted to it and I kept
training and train became the top
student started to fly out to Brazil and
train and then I figured min why not do
what I love I'm one of the head
instructors here for rides of a jujitsu
here in Chicago me and my brother
started this school about 16 years ago
together so we both share the
responsibilities of teaching classes
managing the students how lolly13 how
that's about Salman who work about the
health alert I leave him were assaulted
him in Islam or slapping Islam level
what was originally in martial arts
we already as a Muslim you have this in
Islam if you look up you see the hadith
the best of you are those who have the
best manners and character so we try to
bring it back to the organic the
original weight and I thought I've not
got a letter yes would you like to try
yeah show you some good yeah okay fine
and uh
one I'll hire to dunya
it was a good break wasn't it I can go
back to what you're doing so I'm making
peace my sabbatical I'm an anti-god the
sole chef Eddie hooligan is a warden of
lips it worked
mashallah mashallah bernama yes ma'am I
sure did that is melody ensure the river
so welcome Sameach help madam animal
Judy noxious any fishy cargo large never
mark less to do in Choctaw Eric come on
yes let's go let's go to the studio you
ready okay mashallah indicator better
advocate a level of 2006 I was preparing
to go to Hajj a lot of steps in Hajj so
I have one Sheikh Sheikh Mohammed over
by my place and we put together a panel
and we had a discussion asking the
questions because it was me and a couple
other brothers who are gonna come with
me to Hajj and from here we made it kind
of like a talk show sit down setup and
we were asking the Sheikh about how as
we recorded it made a nice and sweet
short and then from the from there the
Sheikh really liked it and it's been
over ten years now five hundred plus
episodes at hamdulillah and from there
we started off putting it out on the
internet and we got involved with can TV
here in Chicago they've been great I'm
Eddie host of the Dean shown to
everybody all over the globe thank you
for supporting the Dean show thank you
for sharing our programs the daya is in
the hands of the Creator Allah we cannot
guide people but Allah has instructed
all of us to go ahead and the little
that we know to pass it along to pass it
along to humanity that's the least that
we can do and I've seen that hamdulillah
this has changed my life and when I saw
the impact that it had not only on my
life but other people's lives masala tea
vodka man Verna mizuna IDI Jamie didn't
like in the Yemeni actor will admin and
neighbor Nam general basically boring
Allah Hafiz kana kana rare Islamic and
in America Lahore a laburnum jp-8 an
Islamic America shoe for alarm slimming
we're like in the house hadith Madera
and now your Burnham Giada panelist
Lamia Alexandria muslimeen Yasha dune
muhawwil Islam
oh my hair - Adam in Islam had to do
with Lila illa de la Habana without I
said I was promised a lot about what do
they I don't speak say it in Arabic
oh ma Felicia Kim limited or with me
yeah how we are in America and make it
so coming soon the D show to guide us
you shop around the show shall I bend in
that shop thank you